[Music]
when your children get married
you
do not have the moral
ethical
right
to hold on to
their stuff
period
when they reach adulthood
you do not have the moral ethical right
to hold on to their stuff
and so example in our house would be
uh
denise comes home from college
and she sets up her own household within
three months
moves into an apartment with some
roommates
eventually starts dating a guy gets
married
but when they're engaged
i look down and realize there's a file
here with mutual funds with her name on
it
there's the health insurance is still
running through us which is stupid this
is like a grown woman right
and she needs to pay her own light bill
she needs to check the date on her milk
carton
by
herself uh and her mama don't need to do
it yeah and her dad doesn't need to hold
her hand because he looks at her husband
as a little boy yeah
sorry folk
you don't have that option
and when you do
continue your helicopter parenting
into their 20s
you damage the relationship with them
potentially for the rest of your lives
and you stunt their emotional growth
because they're still freaking little
baby children
because you didn't give them any
grown-up stuff to do yeah god that
pisses me off
set them free
the bible says to leave and cleave
so you leave your mama
and take your stuff with you you know
what i heard in that call too though i
wish so bad she had called because i
heard in his voice he didn't want to
talk to him he wasn't supposed to anyway
but even if he was you know he was bowed
up he was ready to talk to him yeah but
it was like this nervousness like you
could hear like well i don't know
he started out with they were nice
people and i started laughing because i
knew he was lying we both well we both
did because we were like but we were
waiting for the bus where's the butt
cause he's a great canceler in a
sentence everything that comes before
the word but means that those people are
butts
so then but i wish we could have talked
to her because i got the sense that she
was not the type that wanted to talk to
them
she's been used to daddy taking care of
no and here's the thing so then speak up
girl speak to that person speak to the
the timid the child the adult child
that's scared to talk to their parents
give them some
some help here is your job as a 20 what
was she he said he was 24 so yeah i
think so yeah she's 23 25 probably give
or take i mean be a grown up come on put
your big girl pants on
and uh because the sooner you do that
the the
the most one of the most rich
times of our lives in our pers personal
family is the current time where i have
adult to adult relationships with my
children including my sons-in-law my
daughter-in-law
and um
i thoroughly enjoy them
as adults but that means that i have to
i you know
rachel and i have uh i don't cross
boundaries with her just like i don't
with you
and you're you know you're we're not ken
right we've been friends a long time
we've been on our team a long time we've
got a good relationship but i i there's
things i can't tell you to do
it's not my right and vice versa by the
way you know and so you know and the
same thing's true with rachel true uh
and so
you know i i we can we could talk about
stuff we can argue about things we can
discuss politics we could talk about
life or religion or doctrine or whatever
else but that's just on a friend of
friend level so to speak yeah and it's
the most rich time it's some of our
ramsay dinners because we're all loud
and gregarious and fun people
are hilarious now but it's like a group
it's like a friend group having dinner
right not you know dad is holding court
and you're all they're going to now
listen to me right they quit doing that
a while back i'll just tell you what do
you think what do you think is going on
in the dad in that scenario that wants
to hold on to it does he still see him
as a kid
he likes the power control i'm talking
to is him because he pisses me off
because he's he's he's being a twerp
he's trying to hold on to the past and
you know you walked her down the aisle
you placed her hand in his hand dude you
just gave her away that's what they call
that all right what if she's not married
well she's 25 though well same thing
except there's not a hand there's
nothing right leaving in cleveland
clarify marital relationship but they're
still adults and so what you're doing is
you're tr you're treating your 25 year
old like she's 13 and guess what she's
going to function like she's 13 and then
the rest of us in society have to put up
with this entitled little twit
don't you think
yeah you have people
that are uh
five years younger than you that you run
into that are not functioning
at that age yeah emotionally well and
it's a very it's an unhealthy dynamic on
both sides because you have the uh let's
use the daughter in this scenario could
be a son either way but the adult child
that will not stand up to mom or dad or
speak up to mom or dad or say i'm a
grown up these are my xyz funds policies
whatever and then you have the dad or
the mom whoever that is
dominant controlling they like having
the power they like being the big you
know big deal in the family and so they
it's it becomes this dynamic that's
unhealthy and on both sides they both
have a responsibility in it is what i'm
saying it is emotionally hard
admittedly
to when your kids reach the point that
you're no longer allowed to tell them
what to do yeah
i used to just tell you to do stuff and
you freaking had to do it you know
and now i can't do that now i have to
convince you or persuade you like i
would one of my buddies
i've got to talk you into this is good
for you here's why i think this and
depending on how strong i feel about it
you know but i may not even bring it up
at all but this is just reasonable
relationship boundaries and and so
but but
some parents can they have a real
problem
with this boundary of
uh
and saying out loud okay this is like a
grown butt human here i can no longer
tell them what to do yeah or i shouldn't
be
telling them what to do
it shouldn't be effective
someone should stop you from doing it
whether it's the person you're doing it
to yourself your pastor ought to look at
you and go hello
you know something somebody had to give
you a little wake-up call you know ring
the bell for you and go uh you have now
moved into a new phase
you no longer can boss them around
and uh because the interfering
mother-in-law when the kid's 32 and she
still rolls her eyes with the way the
chicken pot pie is made oh my god
that's a classic stereotype yeah
and it's like you don't get to roll your
eyes anymore yeah you like have to be
polite and stuff right you know oh my
god you wouldn't do that at your
friend's house right or if you would you
wouldn't have any friends yeah and yet
you still think you can get away with it
with those that you love the most and
the closest to you yeah and so and it
does go into the financial because the
more when you don't put the weight of
the decision-making on the grown child
they do not develop the strength to make
the decisions
you have to let them feel the weight of
that rent on their back and i imagine
the weight of the grocery shopping and
you go oh my god look what bread just
did yeah i imagine it has an effect on
the marriage too for those that are
married then it's it's stripping them of
some of the dignity of figuring it out
as a couple of communicating as a couple
because mom and dad are still
controlling everything still having a
say still carrying the weight it's like
no like like as a as
you have a fight you're under your mom
yeah
oh my god yeah
yeah
i told rachel
denise in particular i said when you
have a fight and if you want to call
over here and talk to us about it you
better bring them
because otherwise i'm going to point you
right back at him and go hey i already
told him you're now his problem
you did say that i did exactly say that
you
this is the ramsey show